years over what was good so 2018 behind
us it is time for me to give my top ten
of the movies that I saw from 2018 and
yeah you know what we will just jump
right into it number ten is a movie that
I actually almost did not get around to
seeing because I saw the trailers I knew
the premise and I thought this is gonna
be the most insufferable friggin thing
ever I don't want to see it but then I
saw it and while it is not amazing I did
have a lot of fun with it
and that is ready player one so I think
I was probably about a half hour into
this movie when it clicked in my head
exactly what it was that I was watching
because I was having to struggle in my
brain between the enjoyment I was having
watching this and the stupidity of it
and then it clicked in my head I know
what this is this is a young adult
dystopian
for geeks in their 30s and 40s and well
as soon as I click that into my head
like if we don't require you know
divergent or Twilight or you know any of
that you know that that entire sub-genre
to be master works of narrative why
would I require of this then I was on
the wavelength that I was able to enjoy
yeah it's fun it's dumb but it's fun and
seeing just the mash-up of of the
different properties honestly did add a
little bit of enjoyment it wouldn't have
worked if the story wasn't you know
didn't have decent momentum and if you
know Spielberg wasn't as good a director
as he was but since you know the story
does have good forward momentum and it
know
when to speed up and a knows when to
slow down and the characters are
likeable enough and Spielberg is just
really good at this that meant that all
the pop culture stuff and seeing all
these characters match together was
icing on a cake as opposed to you know a
little bit of decent seasoning on a
terrible dish which is what it would
have been I think in the hands of almost
any other directors so yeah surprise
inclusion there next up and this is
gonna be one of our couple of different
films that I will mention but you will
not see any images of or from because it
was a paramount release and Paramount's
paramount not only will claim my entire
video because the use of a stake a
single still promotional image about the
movie I'm talking about but they will
not let down even when I go hey this is
fair use could you cut me some slack
here and they still won't so there'll be
a couple of movies on here that yeah I
can't show images of so despite having
enjoyed this movie paramount so that
brings us to a quiet place I suspect a
lot of people will have this a lot
higher on their list I do i I do like it
a lot it was a very good movie it was a
great conceit it was definitely a unique
movie going experience because I don't
think I've ever been in a theater that
quite like a theater that had people
like I've been to screenings were like
there's nobody else here but like that
hat was well attended that was that
quiet it and if you missed it in the
theater you kind of missed out on the
experience because you know knowing that
normally in a movie theater you're
hearing people shifting in their seats
you hear the crinkle of a wrapper on
candy you know you hear somebody leaned
over and whispered something to whoever
to have all of that gone have true dead
silence in a theater because everybody
watching is afraid to make noise that
was a really cool experience like I said
it's lower on my list then I think most
other critics will probably have it you
know for people who don't just have
nothing about art films because honestly
it started out really weak for me it you
can see my review proper for why that is
but it had it had to overcome a big
deficit at the front end and but it did
and it it's just a really good execution
of this whole concept alright next up we
get to start talking animated films and
we are gonna begin with Teen Titans go
to the movies I know a lot of people
don't like Teen Titans go especially
people like the previous Teen Titans
animated series which I should I didn't
like all that much so I never minded
Teen Titans ago but Teen Titans go to
the movies is really fun and really
funny and surprisingly coherent in terms
of keeping a central narrative going and
you know happened it's got a decent
target when it comes
you know there's plenty to make to be
making fun of with superhero movies
right now it does a really good job and
yeah I I thought it was a lot of fun and
I liked the music and I thought the
closing joke I thought was just killer
I haven't mean I love that guy that joke
this is some prizes some surprisingly
dark humor and addition to all the
obvious fart jokes and I actually didn't
even mind those and usually I hate fart
jokes so yeah this was you know we
didn't get we didn't get a lego movie
this year this felt like what we got
instead it's not that far off from the
same level of quality
so moving up from that we are going to
go to another animated film this one did
not appear in theaters don't care my
list my rules so Constantine city of
demons DC animated films really got back
to form this year I was super impressed
to be honest especially for how it is
inconsistent DC animation has been for a
while now
this was really good Matt Ryan back is
constant heating again that's an
automatic you know plus right there
visually was really well put together I
loved the mood and the tone and the
theming and the sacrifices going on it
was just awesome I mean this is
basically anything that I would want
from a Constantine movie it's all there
the you know his the nature of his sort
of relationship with people and with the
supernatural and everything going on
with the demons and some horrific
imagery and you know the the fact that
there's no way that this can be a
completely cleanly happy ending cuz
that's not the world Constantine lives
in oh man this was this was really good
next up we come to number six and this
one is a movie that again I think for
some other people might be a little bit
higher up but like it deserves all the
praise he gets and anyone who wants to
put this as their number one go for it a
you know yeah no hard no no harsh words
for me on that so Black Panther what
Conda was awesome the residents Ville
Conda
we're awesome Sheree was awesome a CO a
was awesome Baku was epically awesome
T'Challa is a great lead kill mongers a
terrific villain claw was a lot of fun
it's so well put together and I
absolutely get why it became the
cultural phenomenon that it did it and I
have nothing bad to say about it there's
absolutely nothing wrong with it
there was just other things that I
enjoyed a little bit more connected with
me personally a little bit more hit my
buttons a little bit harder but this was
Marvel didn't even have to do a great
job for this to have still been a good
movie and a big hit but they did a
job on this so let's get up into the top
five number five the death of Superman
yes not only another DC animated film
but a DC animated film set in the
continuity that I usually hate the one
the the DC animator one based off the
new 52 and adapting a comic book story
that I don't really like how is this so
good
like I'm serious and this this goes
right up there alongside Batman assault
on Arkham
you're comparing that to the Suicide
Squad movie comparing this to Batman V
Superman how are the live-action movies
getting their lunch eaten so hard by
these animated adaptations because this
does everything that when it came to the
death of Superman that Batman V Superman
failed to do it established the value of
Superman as a hero and also with the
perception of his value within the world
that he existed in even though I had
never connected to this version of
Superman particularly they still sold
him all enough that in this movie alone
I got it and I felt the loss and they
did just such a good job leading up to
it building up to it building him as a
character his importance his vitality
you know why it was important that he
would choose to diss accra Feist himself
in this manner it was so good didn't
love the virtus version of Lex Luthor
that's literally the only thing I don't
love about this movie it was great
number four I don't usually do
documentaries I don't watch a lot of
them they they rarely interest me but
won't you be my neighbor was one of the
most uplifting and affirming things I
saw in the theater this year and I am
more than thrilled to put it on here
Fred Rogers was an incredibly
and to see you know his life his
progress his hopes his doubts laid out
and to see people talk about him it it
gives you hope it gives you hope for
people there was somebody that good
there was somebody that loving was he a
perfect human being no probably not
nobody can't be but I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find another human being
who had love like deep unabashedly of
just for his fellow human beings at the
core of almost everything he ever did
whether you grew up watching mr. Rogers
neighborhood or not I think it's good
for your soul to see this movie and I do
highly recommend it now before I get
into my top three I want to do a little
bit of housekeeping now normally right
before I get into the top three is when
I would do my worst movie of the year
and my biggest disappointment I am gonna
mention those but I'm not gonna dwell on
them because I've got some other things
to toss in here as well so first up I
want to mention a couple of movies from
2017 I didn't see until this year and I
want to mention them quickly because if
I had seen them before the year had
ended and before I get my list for the
2017 movies they probably would have
been on there one was the greatest
showmen which is a movie I know a lot of
people have issues with I recognize it
being problematic in the way that it
mythologize is a real-life figure who
was at best a very complicated shade of
gray I did an entire video talking about
that whole concept I still really
enjoyed the movie and I loved the music
so sorry and then additionally shape of
water I didn't see before the year ended
and I was so happy when that one Oscar
for Best Picture because that was great
that that would have been top two if not
top
if not the number one spot if I'd seen
it before the year had ended so there's
that I also want to do an honorable
mention to the comedy special Nanette
Hannah Gadsby's comedy special it became
a bit of a lightning rod which you know
I I found to be unfortunate I found it
incredibly powerful I thought it was I
first of all I did think it was funny
and I also thought it was touching and
moving and devastating in a way that I
am glad I saw I've actually seen it a
few more times since then and I stand by
my thoughts on that one so one other
honorable mention that I want to do I'm
gonna mention my daughter's favorite
movie from this year cuz she and I go to
the movies fair bed you know whenever
it's something that I think she waltz
she a I'm okay with her saying and B I
think she'll like and this one is not on
my top ten and it never really had a
shot but I think I probably liked this
movie a lot better than most adult
audiences did because I kind of got
vicariously to experience it through my
daughter's eyes and not only was this
her favorite movie of the year
this is currently her favorite movie
period and that is a wrinkle in time and
I remember coming out of the theater
going I guess that was okay and she came
out wide eyed and enraptured and in love
with the imagination of it with the
connections between the characters with
the focus of love as a and and finding
what's missing in your life as a central
theme of the fact that the conflict
resolves through emotional connection
rather than combat she loved all of that
and one of the first things she asked me
was when can we buy it and as soon as it
was available I bought it and we've
watched it started together several
times since then at home
and yeah I do appreciate this movie I
still wouldn't say it's great but I see
what she sees in it and I have an
appreciation of it for that reason I'll
also mention really quickly TV I won't
dwell on this but new TV that was out
this year that I really liked was the
new Shira I thought it was great again
became a became highly controversial
which is still weird to me but I thought
it was great
I started watching the good place for
the first time and I've seen you know
I'm current through it so I've seen as
much of season 3 as has currently aired
god I love that show and Westworld
I apparently season two was really
divisive I was shocked to find that out
because I thought season 2 was great
loved it so the dishonorable mentions
really quick so worst movie I saw this
year I'll just mention it and move on
because I've got a whole I've got my
review up on it and that's Cloverfield
paradox it's just dumb and there's no
reason for it to be as stupid as it is I
mean strictly speaking probably the
worst made movie I saw this year was
show dogs which you know I took my
daughter to cos she loves dogs and she
did enjoy the movie but I like knowing
who that was aimed at I was like this is
dumb but it's harmless and then watching
Cloverfield like this is dumb and
insulting cuz it doesn't know it's dumb
and you know at the very least show dogs
knew is stupid now my biggest
disappointment is gonna be a little bit
odd this year because it's not
necessarily the movie I'm out because
I'm gonna say what the movie is it's not
the film as a whole necessarily but it
is one specific element of that film
that I am incredibly disappointed in and
it's it's only gotten worse as time has
gone on and that's Deadpool - I as a
whole I feel it's an inferior film to
the first one in the first place
but the reason I'm I it was such a big
disappointment
may was for a series and a character
that is praised at for self-awareness
and fourth-wall breaking and you know
just having that understanding of its
own genre the fact that it dipped into
one of the most maligned and loathsome
tropes of comic books ie women in
refrigerators ie the female love
interest is killed raped or brutalized
in order to motivate the male hero into
action the fact that this film did that
to Vanessa to Morena Baccarin s
character I would have been frustrated
with any movie that did that but for the
movie that's supposed to be self-aware
to still do that it was infuriating but
let's get back to the positive top three
number three Avengers infinity war oh
boy you know I I did I did have it even
though there's some gap in between I did
honestly when I was first putting this
little list together I have a hard time
figuring out if I was gonna put this or
black panther higher ultimately though I
did know it was gonna have to be this
because as good as Black Panther was
Black Panther didn't make me cry this
made me cry so that's that's usually an
easy ticket onto on to a top ten list is
getting legit tears out of me
so yeah infinity war was worth the wait
Thanos lived up to the hype the action
was intense the threat was real the loss
hit this really did bring back the
memories of when the first adventures
new Avengers movie came out and I guess
it was 2012 and that feeling of it
shouldn't have been possible for this to
work and not only does it work it's
amazing and I felt that again here it
shouldn't have been possible for this to
work and it does
and I just love it top-2
and I went back and forth flipping these
top two over and over and over again as
to what was gonna get cuz then these are
two very different movies that I like
for very different reasons
but this is ultimately how they panned
out so number two spider-man into the
spider verse this one had a leg up in a
couple of areas one I loved animation I
loved especially visually arresting
animation this has that I love
spider-man he's my say he's my favorite
superhero this has six versions of
spider-man so I've got plenty to go on
there I love stories about finding your
own place I love stories about
discovering the potential in yourself
you know not in a trite the power was in
you all along but like really can making
those connections and this story has
that I just man this was good like
there's so much going on but it never
loses sight of miles and it is miles of
story unquestionably from start to
finish
he's great all the alternatives Spider
characters are great his dad's great
this version of oh god I don't even want
to say one is one of the villains the
the particular iteration of one of the
films we get is great the version about
May we get is great like everything is
just so good and it's so cool to watch
and Myles is so endearing um and I just
loved it it didn't quite crack the
number one though because the number one
was from a movie I saw a fairly early in
the year in a way it bears a at least in
terms of my experience of how he got his
number one spot if there's a certain was
almost to get out which was my number
one movie from last year which is that I
saw it relatively early in the year and
it kept worming its way back into my
head
like every couple of weeks I'd find
myself thinking about this movie again
and and not because like man this
thing's now really bugging me but like
just I my brain demanded that I think
about it more and so can't show you
picture cuz it's a paramount release but
annihilation annihilation is everything
that I want in sci-fi based horror
because so often sci-fi horror is just
horror classic set in space it rarely
takes proper advantage of science
fiction concepts this does the horror in
this is visceral at times is brutal at
times but it's also existential it's
also you've requires a lot of thought on
your part to even grasp what's going on
to get the full concept of exactly what
makes this so horrifying it's visually
stunning it is gorgeously grotesque at
times some of the visuals in this film
are amazing it is a true step up from an
already great debuts the second film
from Alex garland who did ex machina
which I also really liked the
performances are solid the visuals are
amazing the progression is incredible
the the way concepts are given they're
given visually there's not a ton of
exposition here it's largely just
showing you and you have to figure out
what it is you're seeing on your own and
I feel like there's just enough
information given that you can figure it
out and but it's also not about figuring
out the logistics of everything because
it it's all
maduk it's all it's got all these themes
going about evolution about change about
refinement about personhood it's oh man
it's not for everybody yeah I was about
to say if you haven't seen it go see it
the thing is I there have been a lot of
people that I you know friends who are
people I've known who said you know what
was the best movie you saw this year and
I tell them like I'm gonna tell you what
it is but I'm also not gonna recommend
you watch it cuz I know you well enough
and you won't like it
annihilation is not everybody's cup of
tea but it was exactly my cup of tea and
it was delicious so that's my list best
movies of 2018 what is your top 10 or
top 5 or top 1 or whatever whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
you can do there too cuz there's buttons
and links including whether the patreon
if you're feeling generous it will be
immensely appreciated but if you don't
want to there's other links as well
check those out you don't even want to
do that that's ok too because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is a joke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]